hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen jetzt seinem neuen video
waren vor einer stunde bei snap zeit
gefragt ob er als heutiges video
entweder ein gaming video oder ein real
live video haben wollte da konntet ihr
screenshots bestimmen was sich hochladen
soll die innovative idee screenshot wenn
ihr real life world hat insgesamt 3000
irgendwas screenshot und screenshot wenn
ihr gaming volt hat nur 1500 jetzt nach
einer stunde bekommen deswegen hier ein
realer video und ihr seht mich dann
schaltet man diese kameraposition an
feierte das so hoch ist ich habe gedacht
wenn ma das macht kann ich das auch herr
emba ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon im
titel gelesen ich bin das cockpit
ich bin auf die idee gekommen eine real
live video zu machen über sachen die ich
damals im kindergarten gebaut habe ja
wie bin ich darauf gekommen ich wurde
einfach auf diesen facebook video
markiert von diesem kit ich bitte euch
jedoch einen kleinen ausschnitt ein und
als nicht mehr das video angeschaut
haben hat meine mutter das gesehen wie
ich mir das angeschaut und dachte ich
wäre dieses kind manche nachtschicht als
auch samen oder malte die familie luca
wir haben auch von picassos man hat sie
mir so ein paar gegeben und wir hatten
drei stück im keller uns meinte luca du
hast selber im kindergarten auch mal
lecker so gebaut dass für junge mama
hast du wieder noch als ob ich damals
schon gebaut hat und sie so ja die ja
hier
ich habe da luca drauf geschrieben und
ein pokemon aufkleber oder sind noch
noch viel mehr
pokémon auch in die ja ich war ein
ziemlich großer pokémon 10 damals
sondern hat sie mir die einfach gegeben
und ich so ja auch cool darf darüber
eigentlich ein video machen dass ich so
alle kindergarten sachen die er macht
die soll ein oder auch raus und jetzt
das ist so ihre dass das einfach
funktioniert es funktioniert tatsächlich
nicht so gut dann meine ich so jung hast
du vielleicht noch mehr sachen die ich
nie wieder was gebaut haben die realen
luca du hast er tatsächlich noch lecker
so damals gebaut
da
da kann das ganze video soll aber nicht
nur weil diese beiden komischen kwg ich
weiß ich mache eigentlich mit einem
sachen so wenig niemand brauche das
einfach über meinen schultern
videospeicher aber dass gerade sind
nein ich habe die eine gerade wieder
repariert aber das gummi gerade
abgegangen also ich hab die wirklich nur
somit zum mit- sondern pub
klopapierrolle gemacht die ein bisschen
geld an meinem fokus hier das doch jetzt
mal alter was soll diese scheiße hier
einmal eine klopapierrolle und dann hier
vorne ein gummiband darüber über so
backpapier kann man eine kassel bauen
und das ist natürlich einzigen sachen
die ich im kindergarten mal gebaut hatte
und zwar habe ich auch so eine komische
raupe hier tatsächlich mal gebaut er
fragt mich nicht warum oder was dann
guckt euch das mal an also dich meinte
jeder der angst vor clowns hat scheint
spätestens jetzt wahrscheinlich das
video einfach abgesägt
na ja es ist sogar treppen oder guckt
euch daran das ist doch was soll man
also man kann es halt nicht aufhängen
weil hier oben ist nicht mal eine
schlaue oder so das ist aber das
aufhängen will wenn es einfach runter
also ja dieses clowns raufen ging habe
ich im kindergarten auch noch gewollt
und ich habe sie muss auch ja gebaut
hier schaut sie euch an der theke sogar
fliegen glaube ich oder also er hat mir
das flügelspiel heißt aber wenn man den
so zeigt es ist gar nicht so etwas halte
aber das ist ja ich finde das hier ist
andino und der kann auch fliegen glaube
ich ich habe aber tatsächlich noch in
dino gebaut
der ist aber ein bisschen verkrüppelt
also ihrer ist dass der hier so dass
tarantino den kann man sogar so bewegen
dass er so laufen kann weil ich hab das
extra hiermit zu coolen teilen dran
gemacht es mag also die beine zu bewegen
kann dass er theoretisch auch so stehen
kann dass er theoretisch irgendwie so
laufen kann den schwanz kann bewegen
können ruhig denn hier diesen guido habe
ich hier auf jeden fall barschel und
dazu noch diesen kino und die beiden
mögen sich ganz toll und sie umarmt ihn
und ja das habe ich auch gebastelt ich
meinen respekt zu ich sehe die ganze
sache gerade auf dem tisch liegen aber
das ist einfach
ich hatte schon bevor das kühlbehälter
[ __ ] euch man von wann ist es also die
isu ist glaube ich von 2001 oder sollte
die habe ich mit fünf jahren gebaut und
ich habe gerade noch etwas entdeckt was
tatsächlich von 1999 habe ich dieses
ding gebaut ist soll sondern walnuss
instrument der ja ich war heftig damals
auch sehr tolles ich habe eine eine tüte
einfach mal ab doch auch im keller
gefunden also dass das ist irgendwie das
ist ein freund von mir der heiß martin
und hier unten bin ich und irgendwie
pinkelt der auch mich traurig die gal
hat keine ahnung dass die zahl von
melissa 2003 liga da war ich sieben also
mit sieben kamen eigentlich schon besser
malen oder luca dann habe ich irgendwann
auch die wasserfarbe entdeckt und hab
dann tatsächlich ein bild von den von
mir nach und fitnessstudio gemalt
jugendlichen nbc
das sieht genau so aus wie ich oder
casino differenz ich war auch irgendwie
früher total der musiker aller gewalt
neben diesen tabus und so habe ich auch
noch rasseln gebaut ist dann einfach zu
probieren dann glaube ich wo ich die
scherben reingelegt hat und dann einfach
so mit diesem tapeziert ships da
blättchen drauf geklebt haben dann hat
man so mein gott jetzt fängt ja auch
noch weg hier hab ich richtig viel
scherben reingepackt dem ein kanal der
abonnieren als ich weil ich mich mal so
zum affen das ist nicht einfach selber
sofas kaputtgegangen gerade diesen hut
hier habe ich auch noch irgendwann
gebaut ich könnte da hab ich gedacht ich
meinen namen geschrieben hat mich
verschrieben und habe kinder noch mal
ins dunkel
dann habe ich auch noch michal
zahlencodes monster allgemein als karius
und baktus jährlich da ein paar sabine
zahnbürste ich glaube das war beim
zahnarzt im wartezimmer bei meinem
ersten zahnarzttermin das hier unten
soll glaube ich kotze darstellen oder so
dann habe ich hier noch eine seine
raupen kette irgendwie gemacht oder
stirnband keine ahnung als ich habe ein
komplettes outfit eigentlich mal
gebastelt oder ihr müsst wissen dass ich
aufarbeiten übelster hot wheels fan war
und danke meine eltern beziehungsweise
nicht nur meine eltern sondern vor mama
und papa mit zwei großen pelé und das
ist hot heads up ist ich doch nicht hot
wheels nicht sondern eher wales da habe
ich dieses tolle auto hier gemacht ich
habe ferrari focus c-max 4 400 400 430
430 euro kostet und die allerletzte
sache die ich gemacht habe war in der
zweiten klasse im winter 2004 ihr könnt
bei den kommentaren raten was hier
darstellen soll das
für mich ist da wir sehen hier
tatsächlich gehalten hand und wie kommt
es sofort wenn dieses kind den
kindergarten hinter jedem dingen die
intention hat und ich habe einfach
irgendwas gemacht wird ist nachher mit
luca betitelt und dort geht alles schief
was kostet ist für die mülltonne und an
dieser stelle beendet als auch das
heutige video will wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen vielleicht denke jo luca du
kannst echt überhaupt nicht basteln aber
irgendwie was witzig mich interessiert
auch eure meinung in den kommentaren
also warten wir früher auch so
bescheuert der auch so viele komische
sachen gebastelt oder vielleicht habt
ihr euch einmal beim basteln die lippe
geschnitten weil das hab ich auch mal
gemacht in der grundschule sonst sehen
wir uns im nächsten video wieder sagt
mir was ihr als nächstes an real life
haben wolf war den ball ja ganze micro
links hier wieder scheiße